- I'm calling you right now
from a Windows 10 computer.
What is gonna be different when I upgrade
to Windows 11?
- I would say the experience, right?
It's modern and more importantly,
it's centered on you.
Even just that little subtle shift
of the start in the center,
centered, centered, centered,
centered, centered around you.
- [Joanna] There it is, from
the king of Microsoft himself.
In Windows 11, the company's
next big operating system
due out later this year,
the start button moves
to the bottom center.
(happy music)
But that cosmetic change
actually has deeper meaning.
The word.
- Center.
- [Joanna] Is core to
Satya Nadella's vision
that Windows 11 should be at the center
of your digital life
as Apple and Google entice users
to increasingly closed off worlds.
He wants Windows 11 to
be a compelling choice
for people who don't wanna
live exclusively in either.
- Windows has a role to play
as that most open of ecosystems today
that plays nicely with,
in fact, the others.
We want you to be able
to connect your phones
to your PCs.
We want you to be able to
communicate to people on phones
or other PCs.
- [Joanna] The proof is in the features.
Windows 11 can now run Android apps.
To learn more about the new software,
Microsoft gave me an exclusive interview
with the company's CEO and chairman.
I know there's a new start sound
and I wanted to know if you
could do an impression of it.
- I wish, I need more talent.
(lively Windows music)
- I took away three
things the company's doing
in this new operating system
to lure users and app makers.
Number one, a new new modern interface.
Those who remember Windows
8 know that messing
with the Start menu
before didn't work out
so well for Microsoft.
There's not somebody's job at Microsoft
which is how should we
move the Start button,
where should we move it?
- I'm sure it is as well
and we'll always have also have the option
with Windows as you know,
we'll always have the option for anybody
to go back to whatever
classic mode they want.
- [Joanna] But the placement is only part
of the fresh Start.
Click the button itself
and you get your apps
but also cloud-connected recommendations
of what you might need next.
- The design system of Windows
is about you getting to your apps,
your files, the people you
wanna connect with faster,
with less friction.
- There are lots of other interface
and design changes.
This button on the taskbar
brings up a widget screen
where you can view all sorts of news
and quick glance information.
Hover on the maximize window
button and you get a tool
to help you place multiple
windows side by side.
These screenshots provided by Microsoft
were taken on pre-release software
and the features are not final.
Tell me, what kind of
role did the pandemic play
in the development of Windows 11?
- We definitely were influenced
by the need for a modern operating system.
In some sense, the
original idea of Windows
has suddenly become, again in 2021,
a huge priority.
- [Joanna] One of those
pandemic-driven features,
a universal mute button
that lives in the system tray
so you don't always have to go digging
in whatever video calling app
to mute yourself.
I'm very into it.
The second thing, a new
store with Android apps.
- We're gonna welcome all apps
across even all the different
application platforms
in Windows itself.
It can be a PWP or a web app.
It can be a native app
and we're gonna support
Android as first class as well.
- All right, tech translation.
Up until now the Microsoft Store
was just for certain
kinds of Windows apps.
(text buzzing)
Now it will be open for any Windows app
but the real headline,
Microsoft is partnering with
Amazon's Android App Store.
Tell me a little bit about
what you're doing with the Microsoft Store
on Windows 10 and specifically there,
what you're doing with Amazon.
- In fact, you can go to our store,
search, find an Android application
and then you'll be linked
into the Amazon Store
and you can use the Amazon Store apps
as if they're Windows apps
and all of the windowing will work.
- [Joanna] It's a big move
and one clearly aimed at Chromebooks,
which also run Android apps.
In the last year, unit sales
of Chromebooks grew by 275%.
Windows 11 will also
enable more Windows apps
to run on new laptops and desktops powered
by ARM mobile chips from Qualcomm.
- If you think about the traditional role
of operating systems,
operating systems are very much needed
whenever there is a real change
in the system architecture.
I mean, you think about the AI chips now,
it's not just the CPU and the GPU
but now MPUs are all
becoming part of any PC.
- Another translation.
All of these parts of the chip set
have changed in big ways
in the last few years
to make computers smarter
and more power efficient.
Windows 11 will work better with them.
And that brings us to the
third: a focus on openness.
Why Windows?
Why should someone get Windows
over Chrome, over macOS?
- Windows gives you the
most choice of systems,
to apps, to everything that
you wanna be able to do.
I think Windows, in fact,
is becoming increasingly the device
that bridges all of these ecosystems.
- Do you think of yourself
as sort of the Switzerland
there of the ecosystems?
- I think that more than
when we say Switzerland,
I think there are certain platform rules
by which we principally drive Windows.
I'm not saying that other ecosystems
shouldn't have their own platform rules.
We have a different set of platform rules
and those platform
rules, I believe, in 2021
are more needed than they ever were.
- How are your platform rules
different than say Apple?
- One simple thing, we have the ability
to have multiple
marketplaces that can thrive.
We wanna have a great marketplace
but we also welcome other marketplaces.
We wanna have great tools like say Teams,
but we also welcome Zoom or Slack
or anything else to be also first class.
- Apple's iOS specifically does not allow
for third-party app stores
and has been the focus of
recent anti-trust scrutiny.
So if you have an Android phone,
it works great with Windows.
What about the iPhone?
- We would love to make sure
that it works better.
I mean, we do everything we can.
Like anything that Apple wants to do
with Windows, whether
it's iTunes or iMessage
or what have you, we would welcome that.
But overall, we wanna make
sure our software runs great
on Apple devices
and Windows works well with any software
from anyone, whether it's Google or Apple
or Adobe or anyone.
- But what Mr. Nadella's
biggest challenge seems to be,
moving ahead without alienating those
who love Windows of yore.
I wanna read you something you said
in your first event as Microsoft CEO
and this was in 2014.
You said, "This business
does not respect tradition."
- What it respects is innovation
on a go-forward basis.
So it's really our collective challenge
that we now need to make Microsoft thrive
in a mobile-first and a cloud-first world.
- How do you innovate
with avoiding a disaster
like Windows 8?
- It's all about the batting average
at the end of it all.
The fact that here 35
years after its inception
and there's no innovation
that's risk free.
So let's say that.
And then boldly go forward.
- But don't worry,
you can still move your start button
to where it's always been.
11, it's a big number.
It's a lucky number, 11 is a lucky number?
- Oh, it is a lucky number.
Two ones make 11.
- Two ones make 11.
Also add up to two.
(Satya chuckling)
- There you go.